there was a story about a family at  disney world that was enjoying a  vacation and they were having a nice  picnic at the end of the day the little  toddler boy of the family wandered out  into the drink just a little bit and a  real alligator  sprung out and ate the boy  so the dad  he grabbed the boy by the wrists  but by now the alligator has the boy up  past the feet past the waist and and  that has to be a very emasculating  devastating experience where you have to  concede defeat in a tug-of-war with an  alligator when your boy is the rope  i  get that [ __ ]  oh  but you try it honey it's a goddamn  alligator  this whole vacation was your idea